du coup changement de pour y avait plus
grand chose mais voilà c'est pas mal
c'est pareil dans la même lignée ça
tombe bien isolé mais bien ancien aussi
c'est super beau et j'ai fait un petit
lancer y avait déjà quelques merde bon
c'est parti on va voir ce qu'on peut
trouver
déjà il a été lourd direct
d'accord mais tu as quand même des
petits morceaux une cuillère je crois
me camille way
up nouilles au calibre 12 ouais
c'est entendu lui aussi par les montres
voiture ouais
une pièce
5 centimes 5 centimes d'euros devient
encore une douille
la chaleur qui a pas compris que vous
pouvez jeter à la poubelle dante évident
encore encore elle est super longue
celle là dans 70 objets quelque chose
aubin encore et ça c'est des morceaux de
voiture un grand sort depuis tout à
l'heure alors je vais manger un bout de
mauvais tu repenses
ouhlala ouais ont bien vu ouais ouais
réussi
que ceux-ci rasta
d'un copain
vas-y à la nage
montrons lui que t'es pas une chochotte
entre lui
et le copain
encore une benne donc ça tu vois ça
montre que vraiment peu importe le poids
en fait il ya des choses cachées un peu
partout et c'est là les courtes par
contre est ce une course de prestige
dans intéressant que vous continuez à
avancer les morts alors continuez pas à
l'abri d'un calibre 12 h et quelque
chose à savoir l'eau
une serre en selle de moto
est encore une douille
olala ça promet elle est grande à
l'énorme travail
hossa bull
ait quelque chose à
au regarde une ampoule
une led ces paumés mais ils ont jeté de
tous
voilà du coup on a les manques coincé
une péniche qui arrive donc on a bien
mis la corde sous l'eau et vu que les
péniches ses aplats normalement il n'y
aura pas de souci mais on sait jamais
combien ça on a lâché la corde
c'est bon
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'il reste de votre
rang je pense qu'à des dingueries
propos non t'inquiète séraphin ses
morceaux de bagnols ou si c'est un
morceau de bagnes otages connaît oui oui
vous avez une idée du modèle va ça fun
moto je pense du coup ses gros seins oui
mais dans des groupes de celles qu'on le
gros à la vendre avec la salle carrée
assis là au bout il est beau aussi
laisser leurs enfants ouais alors
attention français c'est
1971 un franc parce que je veux faire
une sorte de harnais de ceinture gros
chien et hawaïens d'un colis où il avait
une grosse tête c'est un gros chien
soirée je pense que restaurant va lui
donner ce qu'il en pense mais alors le
colis péché lointain il te plait
mais non faut pas le manger
allait bien on met le colis péché
c'est bien regardent comme si tout va
bien
donc là j'ai des trucs
s'est remplie or si l'on
regarde aussi un piège
c'est génial trop stylé leur bon état
c'est un piège à loup
il s'agit des pièges à mâchoires ou s'il
appelait parfois pieds jaloux kg renard
ce genre de piège est interdite depuis
1995 en france donc quelle que soit la
nature des mâchoires et les garnitures
éventuel ça explique sûrement la raison
pour laquelle nous l'avons retrouvée au
fond de l'eau en tout cas n'hésitez pas
à nous dire en commentaire si vous
souhaitez une restauration de ce piège
on se fera un plaisir de la faire ta
mort ouais ça va
un peu de coups morceaux de motos de
voitures
merci on aurait oublié
un
âge était coordonnateur
[Musique]
ils sont pas de consommateurs
s'acquitter contre nous non hélas nous
si lointaine
et pièges à loup ça c'est sympa ça away
we go wigan
wayne belles motos l'ancien
haut
ce que tu as fait encore et or est
dessous
c'est peut-être l'autre côté
ouais moi aussi j'en refais voir dans la
les chasseurs ils ont vraiment abusé là
c'est sûrement la seule
non
non en vrai c'est rare qu'on trouve
autant comme ça des fois il y en a une
de temps en temps
ouais ouais
oui c'est vrai c'est un peu con
pourtant les laisser sur place au moment
où tu as tiré quoi bon il assume pas
vis-à-vis de ses camarades de chasse ça
vient
au cecos de marque
depuis d'accord alors leur trempé par
contre
la marque c'est une portière ou piotte
déjà là 4 ritmo 105 pc fiat ritmo 150 et
ses bons mots et pas du tout mettre une
photo de quoi ça ressemble à celle
qu'offre je crois est elle la clé la
fiat ritmo 105 tc donc petites voitures
sportives sorti en 1983 qui se voulait
être la rivale de la golf donc c'est
plutôt intéressant de trouver ça ici
c'est une voiture qui était sûrement
beaucoup volé à l'époque pas mal de
temps que nous attend au fond de l'eau
oh c'est quoi ces montres
et non en bêtise regarde quoi les régler
si petit
nombre d'enfants est bizarre ouais et
ses devoirs soient pas d'autres bijoux
avec chauffeur ouais ses rangs de peu
bravo français bravo bravo à trésor de
guerre
ouah
ouah à soleure il est magnifique les
détails pas s'apprendre angevins aussi
beau on fait les branchies tout bel et
bien été mon dieu qu'est-ce qui fait
atteint ici fait la star fait n'importe
quoi dessin escalade allait bien saute
dans l'eau
bien là
qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est pas correct
ça ce comportement reste à on espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu en tout cas pour
nous c'était une vraie partie de plaisir
de nettoyer cet endroit on a fait
quelques belles découvertes n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la semaine
prochaine